joining us online is documentary
filmmaker ami horowitz he took to the
streets
of new york to ask people if they knew
about some of the racist things that joe
biden had said here's a little bit of
what that sounded like
the quote about barack obama being
bright articulate and clean
joe biden really
wow and that was his vp like
wow yeah little surprise yeah
the quote about uh you ain't black no
vote for me was
joe biden he said that he did say that
why
you seem blown away yeah cause it's just
like someone who's i'm not gonna lie an
open democrat like
you would expect that when you represent
that party you wouldn't
feel comfortable saying things like that
ami
welcome back to the show a pleasure
so i'm gonna be here yeah so um
apparently you just decided for this one
not to go
into an incredibly dangerous place and
instead just to stay in your normally
dangerous place which is new york
all right and uh and just to ask people
on the street about joe biden quotes why
don't you explain
what your latest adventure was about
this time
yeah so there's this office's working
theory that um
that president trump is is an absolute
raging racist
uncontrollable racist and is always
making incredibly racist remarks
and joe biden is of course the protector
and the democratic party writ large
are the protectors of the democratic
party so i want to put that to the test
in a couple of ways and the first way i
did it was i i i kind of show i
gave people these quotes did a kind of a
game show for
fun game show format we could win great
prizes and we
we gave them a quote a blind quote
without saying who said it
and we had him rate how racist that
comment was
i gave them the four most racist uh
comments that
joe biden's made and the four quote
unquote most racist uh comments
that president trump has made and if and
as you can probably guess this point
that the trump quotes were actually not
racist at all in fact they're looking at
me saying
those are actually true statements so
they don't rate as racist
while joe biden said shockingly
shockingly
racist statements and and then after
that i
revealed who it was and they were kind
of looking to be kind of strange that
their head was spinning
i then moved on to the more important
question which is does the democratic
does it seem to you that if a guy the
guy who's running for your vote
feels comfortable enough making these
statements does that make a
larger statement of the democratic party
have they taken you for granted they all
looked at me they thought about it for a
second
and they all looked at me without
exception they said yeah i think they
are they are taking advantage of us and
they are taking us for granted i thought
it was pretty enlightening
so i'm looking forward to the follow-up
video in which they all announced that
they're still voting democrat next time
there's an election
in new
i know i'm just i'm a little cynical
because i mean the fact is that the
right has been pointing out this sort of
ridiculousness for for quite a while now
uh were they really were they really all
that shocked when they learned that it
was joe biden that it said all these
things
yeah most were pretty shocked um look
here's the thing
there's just inertia is an incredibly
strong physical property right and
you've had
generations of americans
voting for the democratic party so that
inertia is strong and it takes
an incredibly strong force outside force
to push that inertia and to stop the
inertia process
and to push them off that track to
reverse their process it is possible
it is possible to do and i think we're
making inroads and that's the reason why
president trump took a larger percentage
of the black vote
than any republican in recent memory so
ami
meanwhile i may as well get a new york
update from you since you are now
trapped in the wilds of new york i left
la and i was like this place is no good
any longer you're still stuck in new
york so what is your update from on the
ground
in new york how's the administration of
bill de blasio going
so technically right now i'm actually in
the panhandle of florida
oh well welcome to a free state dude
welcome to a free stuff yeah no kidding
i went to a bar last night it was great
um
look it's uh it's it's been bad and it's
getting worse i mean there's just a
shooting
just in the upper west side where i live
yesterday at a church
and a man was killed uh the the the the
home situation has gotten absolutely
worse we thought that actually they were
taking the homeless out of these luxury
hotels
in fact they're not they're still there
and they've been and they and their
friends who have been
aligned with them on the left have been
suing the course to make sure they stay
there
uh no it's getting worse every day i
don't let my daughters walk alone by
themselves and they now have
pepper spray which we never did look
two years three years ago when they were
younger they were able to go somebody's
house for shabbat and walk back at night
we had no problem with it we've changed
our entire
mode of behavior ben so do you think
there's going to be a continued outflow
of people from
new york to places like florida we've
seen in florida a huge outpouring
from new york from connecticut from new
jersey
uh we're seeing it from california as
well i know a lot of people are
wondering after whether when covet is
over
whether that sort of reverses itself but
but it seems like this may be more of a
permanent shift that a lot of people are
starting to see you know democrat
governed cities as places they don't
want to bring up kids
it has nothing to do with coronavirus
this has been this has been going on for
a long time it was accelerated for sure
by coronavirus but this is going on
way before it has nothing to do with it
and that's why i'm afraid that it's only
going to deteriorate
uh after coronavirus is is solved and
put away
all righty well ami horowitz go check
out his brand new
documentary video you can check it out
on youtube over at daily wire actually
you can check it out
exclusively for daily exclusively for us
it's an amazing video it's the greatest
video you've ever seen in your entire
life and you should go check it out
right now daily water and subscribe
while you're at it i'll be great to talk
to you
always a pleasure
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content